ya vimos el estadístico he cuadrada en
otros vídeos
ahora vamos a usarlo para hacer una
prueba de homogeneidad con homogeneidad
nos referimos a que tanto se parecen las
cosas entre sí eso es en esencia lo que
vamos a probar aquí vamos a ver dos
grupos diferentes y veremos si las
distribuciones de cierta variable para
ambos grupos son parecidas o no para
ilustrar esto vamos a imaginar que
comparamos las personas diestras con las
personas sordas y nos preguntamos si
tienen las mismas preferencias en áreas
de conocimiento si se inclinan de igual
forma hacia la ciencia tecnología
ingeniería y matemáticas si prefieren
las humanidades o ninguna establecemos
la hipótesis nula y la hipótesis
alternativa
la hipótesis nula es que no hay
diferencia en la distribución de las
preferencias que tienen los diestros y
los zurdos en términos de las áreas de
conocimiento la escribimos como no hay
diferencia en la preferencia de áreas de
conocimiento
entre diestros y zurdos
la hipótesis alternativa es que si hay
diferencia en la preferencia de áreas de
conocimiento entre diestros y zurdos
como vamos a probar estas hipótesis ya
hemos visto cómo probar hipótesis en
muchos vídeos anteriores pero aquí vamos
a muestrear dos grupos diferentes aquí
tenemos la población de personas
diestras y acá tenemos la población de
personas sordas tomamos una muestra de
60 elementos de la población de diestros
y también tomamos una muestra de la
población de zurdos las muestras no
tienen que ser del mismo tamaño así que
digamos que la muestra de zurdos es de
40 elementos aquí están los datos que
obtuvimos de dichas muestras de la
muestra de 60 personas diestras 30
personas prefieren las áreas de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas
también abreviadas cti m por otra parte
15 prefieren humanidades y 15 son
indiferentes las prefieren por igual de
la muestra de 40 personas zurdas tenemos
que 10 prefieren ciencias e ingeniería
25 prefieren humanidades y 5 que las
prefieren por igual al final vemos los
totales de personas diestras
personas zurdas así como el total de
personas por preferencia en el área de
conocimiento o si no tienen preferencia
ahora pensemos en cuáles son los datos
esperados si suponemos que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera de que no hay
diferencia en las preferencias entre
diestros y zurdos
esta es la columna de diestros y esta es
la columna de zurdos suponiendo que no
hay diferencia en las preferencias de
área de conocimiento entre diestros y
zurdos nuestra mejor estimación de la
distribución de preferencias de la
población en general por área de
conocimiento vendría de la columna de
total ya que suponemos que no hay
diferencia diríamos que en cualquier
grupo 40 personas de cada 100 prefieren
ciencias e ingeniería es decir 40 por
140 de siempre serían humanidades es
decir 40% y 20 de 100 no tendrían
preferencia alguna es decir 20% así que
el valor esperado es que 40% de los
diestros preferirían ciencias e
ingeniería cuánto es 40 por ciento de 60
0.4 por 60 es igual a 24 del mismo modo
el valor esperado es que 40% de los
diestros preferirían humanidades
40 por ciento de 60 es 24 de nuevo
también esperaríamos que el 20 por
ciento de la muestra no tenga
preferencia alguna 20 por ciento de 60
es igual a 12 al sumar todo esto nos da
60 hacemos lo mismo para la muestra de
zurdos esperaríamos que el 40 por ciento
de ellos preferirían ciencias e
ingeniería 40 por ciento de 40 es 16
esperaríamos que 40 por ciento
preferirían humanidades así que de nuevo
16 es el 40% de 40 sin preferencia
esperaríamos 20% el 20% de 40 es 8
sumamos todo y nos da el total de la
muestra 40 ya que calculamos los valores
esperados es un buen momento para
asegurarnos de que se cumplen las
condiciones para realizar una prueba de
gi cuadrada la primera es la condición
de aleatoriedad por lo que estas
muestras tienen que ser realmente
aleatorias esperamos que esto así sea la
segunda condición es que el valor
esperado para cualquiera de estos datos
tiene que ser de por lo menos 5 así que
si cumplimos con esta condición la
última condición es la de independencia
ya sea que muestre amos conred
o si no lo hacemos así al menos debemos
saber que el tamaño de las muestras no
es mayor del 10% del tamaño de la
población vamos a suponer que esto
también se cumple ahora sí ya estamos
listos para calcular el estadístico he
cuadrada el estadístico he cuadrada es
igual a la diferencia entre lo que
obtenemos menos lo que esperamos al
cuadrado 30 menos 24 al cuadrado
dividido entre lo que esperamos que es
24 hacemos esto para cada uno de estos
datos sumamos 10 menos 16 al cuadrado
entre 16 ahora vemos estos números y
sumamos 15 menos 24 al cuadrado entre el
esperado que es 24 seguimos con estos
dos números sumamos 25 menos 16 al
cuadrado dividido entre 16 vemos los
siguientes los números sumamos 15 menos
12 al cuadrado entre 12 por último vemos
estos dos números y sumamos 5 menos 8 al
cuadrado entre el valor esperado que es
8 ya que calculamos el valor del
estadístico y cuadrada entonces debemos
preguntarnos cuáles son los grados de
libertad
regla general dice que hay que ver los
datos y contar el total de renglones y
de columnas que tenemos y restarle 1 a
cada uno si tenemos tres renglones y dos
columnas entonces los grados de libertad
serán el número de renglones
3 - 1 multiplicado por el número de
columnas
2 - 1 2 por 1 es 2 la razón por la que
esto tiene sentido es porque si
conociéramos estos dos datos y
conociéramos el total de las columnas
entonces podríamos calcular los otros
datos que faltan si conociéramos este
dato y este otro podríamos calcular este
si conociéramos este y este podríamos
calcular este otro de igual forma con
estos dos datos podríamos calcular este
de acá lo mismo aplica para toda la
tabla y es por eso que funciona esta
regla general el número de columnas
menos 1 pone el número de renglones
menos 1 nos dan los grados de libertad
regresando al momento en que calculamos
el valor para el estadístico he cuadrada
cosa que aún no hacemos aquí pero que
ustedes pueden hacer con una calculadora
y tenemos los grados de libertad podemos
encontrar el valor p o la probabilidad
de obtener el valor
el estadístico he cuadrada así de
extremo o más extremo y si este valor es
menor que el nivel de significancia el
cual deberíamos establecer con
anterioridad
entonces rechazaríamos la hipótesis nula
y sugeriríamos la alternativa si esto no
es menor que el nivel de significancia
entonces no podemos rechazar la
hipótesis nula nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo